the real serious discussion would begin
when republicans
released our outline
we have produced a tailored and targeted
draft that will cut right to the heart
of
three distinct crises facing our country
getting kids back in school getting
workers back to work
and winning the health care fight
against the virus
kids jobs and health care
first our nation's kids
chairman alexander blunt and shelby will
be introducing a sweeping package
to help schools and universities reopen
safely
we're talking about more than a hundred
billion dollars
more for an education fund than house
democrats put aside
in a bill that spent multiple trillions
and there are policies to help child
care providers
and schools have the flexibility they
need
to function second jobs
since our nation has one foot in the
pandemic
and one foot in the recovery our
economic policies have to acknowledge
both sides of that coin
chairman grassley will introduce another
round of direct checks for households
at the same amount as before
with even more support for families who
care for vulnerable
adult dependents chairman
collins and rubio have designed a sequel
to their historic ppp
to help prevent more layoffs of american
workers
and republicans want to continue a
federal supplement
to state unemployment insurance
in fact we'll propose a weekly dollar
amount that is eight times what
democrats put in place
when they control the white house and
congress during the great recession
but we have to do it in a way that does
not slow down reopening
we're also going to help this country
pivot into recovery
the american people don't just want
relief they want
opportunity so long as the reopenings
can be saved so chairman grassley will
walk through strong economic incentives
to boost worker retention
get americans rehired and help small
businesses buy the ppe
testing and supplies that will protect
employees
and customers alike senator romney has
legislation to help a future congress
ensure
our critical national trust funds remain
strong and looking to our long-term jobs
future there is no question this
pandemic has america
and our allies re-examining our degree
of dependence
on china chairman graham is introducing
a package of legislation that will
incentivize ppe
manufacturing right here at home
it will ensure that our efforts to
rebuild our national stockpile of
protective gear actually benefit
american workers instead of just
stimulating
china and it will bring a heightened
focus to other key concerns such as the
high-tech semiconductor manufacturing
critical minerals and intellectual
property stuff so the lessons of this
pandemic
do not go unlearned and finally health
care
chairman alexander grassley and others
have already
i've already named have legislation to
keep america on offense
against this virus diagnostics
treatments vaccines
hospitals and health care workers
protecting seniors who rely on
medicare for premium spikes our
legislation supports all of it
at continued historic levels
and tying kids jobs and health care all
together
senator cornyn has authored strong
legal liability protections so that
nurses
doctors charities school districts
colleges and employers can spend the
next months
actually reopening rather than fighting
for their lives against frivolous
lawsuits
will preserve accountability in the
event of gross negligence
or intentional misconduct but we're not
going to let trial lawyers throw a party
on the backs of the front line workers
and institutions who
brought who fought this new enemy on the
front lines
health economic assistance liability
and schools
another historic package for the next
phase
of this historic national fight
to make a law bipartisan talks need to
come next
so there's one big question facing the
country
right now which version
of our distinguished democratic
colleagues
are the american people about to get
we're going to get the democratic party
we got in march
when our colleagues met us in good faith
negotiations and worked with us to turn
our framework
into a bipartisan product
the democrats who helped us pass the
largest rescue package in american
history without one dissenting vote
or will the country get the democratic
party we saw in june
when our colleagues refused to suggest
amendments or
improvements to senator tim scott's
police reform bill
and chose to block the issue altogether
their actions last month left some
observers wondering whether democrats
had made this
cynical choice to give up on bipartisan
legislation
altogether right through november
whether democrats had determined that
strengthening our nation with bipartisan
action might hurt their political odds
and therefore it might suit their
fortunes better
if pain and chaos simply
continued i hope that's completely
off-base madam president i know our
democratic colleagues know this crisis
is still urgent
i know they know american families need
more help
so i hope this strong proposal will
occasion a
real response not partisan cheap shots
not the predictable tired old rhetoric
as those
as though these were ordinary times and
the nation
could afford ordinary politics
we cannot have a senate minority decide
in june it is done legislating
until november the pandemic
is not finished the economic pain
is not finished so congress
cannot be finished either